.
TAMMY: WILL COME BACK TO "THE
BIG SUNDAY SHOW", ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ IN THE SQUAD HAVE
A NEW IDEA TO MAKE THE AGENDA
HAPPEN.
THEY ARE PUSHING BIDEN TO BYPASS
CONGRESS AND USE THE POWER ON
THE 55 POLICIES.
A NEW FOSSIL FEEL RELEASES AND
CANCELING STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
THE PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS TWEETING
TO THE PRESIDENT TO BE GUIDED BY
RACIAL GENDER AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE TO GET THE AGENDA DONE.
TAMMY, I'LL BEGIN WITH YOU, JUST
A SECOND, ADDITIONALLY THE
CONGRESSIONAL BLACK AND HISPANIC
CAUCUSES ARE ALSO EXPECTED TO
ISSUE THEIR WISH/DEMAND LIST IN
THE COMING WEEKS.
THE MESSAGE SEEMS TO BE WE HELP
GET YOU TO THE OVAL OFFICE, IT'S
TIME TO TAKE CARE OF HER ITEMS.
TAMMY: ALL THEY NEED TO DO IS
LOOK AT THE POLLS, AMERICANS ARE
VERY UPSET.
THAT IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT, NO
ONE ELECTED ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ TO BE PRESIDENT.
JOE BIDEN WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE SAID HE WAS A
MODERATE, BACK TO LIFE IS NORMAL
AND LORD KNOWS THEY'RE GIVING
THAT TO US.
THEY HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT AND
YOU HAVE TO GIVE THEM CREDIT IN
THE FACE OF EVERYTHING THEY WILL
NOT STOP, THE ANGRIEST DOG IN
THE WORLD.
THEY'RE PULLING ON THE CHAIN AND
THEY WANT WHAT THEY WANT.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM IT IS NOT
BASED IN REALITY OR WHAT'S BEST
FOR THIS COUNTRY AND IT IS
DANGEROUS.
MY GOODNESS WHAT MORE DO THEY
NEED TO SEE THE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DO NOT WANT
WHAT THEY ARE SELLING AND WERE
REJECTING WHAT THEY'RE SELLING
AND THEY DO NOT CARE, THIS
SHOULD BE A LESSON FOR ALL OF US
ABOUT WHAT IS DRIVING THESE
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUALS, ALL OF
THEIR PLANS AND THE PARTICIPANT
IMPLEMENTED LIKE THE WAR ON
FOSSIL FUELS HAS IN PART LED US
TO THIS POINT WHICH IS INSPIRING
THE ENEMIES THAT WE HAVE AROUND
THE WORLD.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT AOC IS NOT THE
PRESIDENT, AN INSTAGRAM SHE DID
CHANNEL HIM.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I'LL TELL YOU A SECRET A LOT
OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT
CAPITALISM IS, MOST PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW WHAT SOCIALISM IS BUT MOST
PEOPLE ARE NOT CAPITALIST
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
CAPITALIST MONEY, THEY ARE NOT
BILLIONAIRES SPEAK TO CHARLIE?
CHARLIE: THAT WAS TERRIFYING I'M
GOING TO HAVE NIGHTMARES.
ALICIA: I WON'T DO IT AGAIN.
CHARLIE: IT IS AMAZING AND HARD
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THEY ARE
THIS DUMB OR THEY ARE EVIL.
THE REASON WE ARE IN THE
SITUATION WE ARE IN IS BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN AFTER CLAIMING TO BE A
MODERATE WITH POSITIONING
HIMSELF AS A MODERATE RAN OFF ON
THE GREEN NEW DEAL NONSENSE
WHICH LED TO THE EXACT SITUATION
WE ARE IN AND THE SITUATION THAT
WE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE ARE IN.
THEY JACKED UP OIL PRICES AGAIN
VLADIMIR PUTIN ENOUGH MONEY TO
INVADE AND WE TEND TO AMERICA
THAT WE HAVE TO TURN TO
VENEZUELA FOR OIL AND GAS PRICES
ARE GOING TO THE ROOF.
THE ONLY GOOD THING HERE.
THE FACT THAT THE SQUAD IS
TALKING ABOUT FORCING BIDEN TO
RUN OFF WITH THE CIRCUS AGAIN ON
THE CRAZY POLICIES IS PROOF THAT
THEY KNOW AND THEY'VE SEEN THE
PULLING AND THEY KNOW THEY WILL
GET SHELLACKED IN NOVEMBER AND
THEIR BEST CHANCE IS TO DO IT
ALL WITH THE PEN IN THE PHONE.
THAT IS THEIR ONLY HOPE.
ALICIA: AS YOU REMEMBER
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN HIS FIRST
YEAR SIGNED 55 EXECUTIVE ORDERS
SLAMMED BY THE DEMOCRATS.
HE DID DO MORE THAN PRESIDENT
OBAMA WHO IN HIS FIRST YEAR END
ACTED 38.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SO FAR HAS
ISSUED 77 EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
RATHER HE DID IN 2021.
IS THIS THE WAY OF THE FUTURE TO
BYPASS CONGRESS BECAUSE OF NOT
GETTING THINGS DONE AND THAT
ESSENTIALLY WOULD MAKE THE
PRESIDENT KIND OF LIKE A KING?
JOEY: IS THE WAY OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE FUTURE.
OBAMA WAS HANDED LIKE THIS
ADMINISTRATION DID COMING INTO
THE WARS AND SOME OF THAT DIDN'T
MAYBE SOME OF IT NOT.
THIS IS WHAT I WILL TELL YOU
PRESIDENT TRUMP EXECUTIVES ORDER
IS NOT THE SAME AS PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S EXECUTIVE ORDER.
EXECUTIVE ORDER STAYING THE
CRAZY REGULATION THE LAST ONE
GOING TO GET RID OF IS NOT THE
SAME AS WRITING 77 EXECUTIVE
ORDERS TO PUT NEW ROLLS IN NEW
RESTRICTIONS ON OUR ECONOMY AND
THE RESTRICTIONS ON OUR FREEDOM.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM AND THAT'S
WHAT MAKES IT SO HARD TO STOMACH
TO SEE NOT ONLY WHAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS ALREADY DONE FROM THE
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD JOKES IN THE
RADICAL JOKES BUT THE IDEA THE
PRESSURE FROM SOMEONE WHO CAN
SEND A TWEET AND RAISE A MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS AOC THIS IS
SELF-PRESERVATION FOR THE SQUAD
THEY ARE WRANGLING BOTH IN MONEY
LIKE THEY ALWAYS DO BY TELLING
PEOPLE THEY ARE VICTIMS OF.
IT DOESN'T MATTER TO THEM IT'S
NOT A BIG DEAL MOST OF THEM ARE
UPPER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
SECURING THERE SEEM REASONABLE
TO MONEY AND AFTER THEY SECURE
POWER I